bang bang
what's up i'm here with beautiful and
intelligent
and sometimes funny but not always funny
anthony
pompliano welcome to the paulina
marinova pompiano show all right guys
what's going on lunch money time while
wall street's trying to get rich the
rest of us just trying to get lunch
money right
sorry for the blooper there in the
beginning that was not a blooper
uh i think it was that was not uh don't
forget lunch money is now sponsored by
block five
get money get paid go open an account
what's today today's the 17th you got
one more day left until july 18th
use the link in the description open an
account if you fund it
you will earn 2x as much interest in the
month of august
you can earn up to 8.6 apy on an annual
basis no brainer go do it
click on the damn link let's go what's
going on with homes
okay june home construction jumps 17.3
when states reopened so constructions
construction of u.s homes
jumped that much in some states but the
pace still lags
last year after the spring's massive
slowdown and building activity
yeah so construction got shut down all
over the country and
why is this surprising at all well it's
only 17 percent jump
month over month i think it's not year
over year
over year but it is up almost 20
since the month before right in the
month of may so what is more interesting
to me
is one homes are getting built that's
great but two is home prices continue to
rise
and so what you're seeing is there's
this explosion
of construction new home purchases and
used home purchases
all because cheap capital is flooding
the market right but is that true
everywhere that home prices are on the
rise
home prices are on the rise uh
nationally for sure i'm sure there's
certain areas where they're down in
certain areas where it's up but
nationally
home prices are up uh in places like new
york city obviously
you're seeing apartment prices drop
because there's so many
uh vacancies but again this is what
happens and it's also different markets
right like
uh people ask me a lot of time about
real estate i don't talk too much about
it but
take for example a place like new york
city and then let's
talk about georgia for example right in
georgia there's not a ton of
international money that was flowing
into the state of georgia single-family
homes
over the past five years it was you know
americans buying
homes well just people here that live
here in america right
they were buying homes in new york city
though there was tons of international
money flooding in right especially from
asia
they were buying up property sometimes
not even living in them there was
investment properties or just a store of
wealth type play
but what happened was as that boom
occurred over
you know called 2012 13 14 15 and into
like 16 and 17
home uh or building uh manufacturers and
and
builders and developers said wait a
second look at all this money that's
sloshing around let's go build tons of
buildings
and so they started to ramp up
production but by the time that all this
stuff came online
all of the international money because
of capital controls and other reasons
started to actually dissipate
and so now you've got a surplus of
building but you've got
not as much capital demand for it and so
you get prices crashing
the opposite is actually happening in
the u.s single-family home market which
is
there's a surplus of demand
a lot of people don't know this over 200
000 homes per year is the deficit
of the building that we do so there is
uh to keep track
or keep pace with the demand for
single-family homes in the united states
we would have to produce 250 000
more homes than we already do and so
you're getting less supply
increased demand and of course you're
gonna get uh prices going up because of
that
sound good great awesome let's go to the
cruises
the cdc bans u.s cruises through
september due to ongoing outbreaks on
ships yeah i don't think we're going to
be getting on cruises anytime soon i i
think that september is generous
how much would somebody have to pay you
to get on a cruise right now
i've never been on a cruise one because
i get seasick
so literally you don't have enough money
especially right now i mean i would do
it for like a billion dollars but who
has that kind of money to put me on a
cruise you know
well the cruise lines might spend a
billion dollars to incentivize people to
come on the cruises
not a billion dollars not for an
individual but yeah what do you think
their marketing budget is going to look
like when they try to get people to come
back on the cruise that is so crazy
yeah the agency's no sale order was set
to expire on july 24th but troubling
coca data
from vessels forced the cdc to issue an
accenture well first of all let's think
about this
one there's a whole bunch of people on a
cruise all
in the same space two they're generally
older
so then that's a whole different issue
in three it's like
you can't get off true
i don't know you're usually stuck
in like inside right you can go outside
but you're spending a lot of time inside
the other thing too is it's really hard
to keep them clean they're so big and
how many
how many people are you gonna actually
have as part of the cleaning crew right
just increase your cost
do we think the cruise lines survive
i think some fail but like the big ones
survive
bankruptcy is a comment i'm telling you
i know people who
like will go on a cruise the second they
can't will evo
no no no all right i know people who are
already trying to go on the cruises
they're talking about booking them right
now what are you talking about
you uh what's going on with jetblue all
right ready
yeah do your little shake american
airlines yeah everybody knows
hey american airlines is the best
airline no it's not
yeah it is i'm you teamed do you know
why
you know why i know that because jetblue
and american airlines are teaming up
that's not a okay so okay
so american airlines and jetblue are
partnering to allow the airlines to sell
seats on each other's flights and share
frequent flyer benefits
why this is smart it's called bundling
they're they're literally bundling their
services together
although they don't call it that that's
what they're doing why are they doing
that because they're
because now all of a sudden if i
basically say all right if you're an
american airlines
executive platinum member i don't know
who would do that
uh and you want to fly on american
there's not always flights everywhere so
you can fly on jetblue now and use your
points or acquire points do all that
kind of stuff
i'm more likely now to use jetblue than
any other airline
because they're partnered up with
american airlines vice versa is also
true so if i was on jetblue
and american so that you basically what
you're trying to do is you're trying to
find another airline
that doesn't have a ton of overlap with
you
but has enough overlap where uh they're
similar types of customers
but you don't go and say oh 90 of our
customers are shared
and that's basically what bundling
economics does they're not officially
doing it and either
one announcing it as a bundle or two
they're not merging the businesses
but by offering this like joint product
they're essentially testing the water it
wouldn't surprise me
if this works to see others go and
follow it
and also maybe combine the companies a
lot of international airlines do this i
know but
i think this is one of the first
american partnerships
sorry um do you know why i like jetblue
that was the most polite cough in the
world yeah there wasn't a cough
i was clearing my throat do you know why
i like a trap blue why
because they have lights what they have
the blue light on the inside
oh no i don't think that's a thing it
kind of feels like vegas they have free
wi-fi
and they have so many snacks they give
you they like one time i was on a flight
they gave me like three cheese
so i was like do i need all this just
three cheeses or three bags two bags of
cheeses
three only three cheeses would be kind
of not a great snack they're just
they're just
the best you want to know the most
disappointing part of the airline
decision what
they're not doing alcohol service
anymore yeah is that because people get
rowdy and want to socialize
and well yeah yeah and covet no they
don't want to have to engage like they
don't want the staff to engage with
people hopefully it comes back imagine
that you had to take long flights
it's not like you drink that much on
flights like come on
okay so i'll do it when she's not there
all right what's going on netflix
when you're not there i'm like the life
of the party oh i i believe
it i believe it you're still the life of
the party even when i'm there today in
the elevator i call them
chatty kathy because we cannot go
anywhere without
you chatting somebody up i'm nice to
people
literally they don't want to talk and
he's chatting he's
what do you mean they don't want to keep
that person on the flight that you have
your headphones in and he's like
hey you mean the guy that
is at the front desk that when we walk
by talks us every time and i respond
while everyone else is an [ __ ] and
walks by no you don't respond you
and get you start the conversation okay
i don't think saying hi is starting to
come all right let's go on netflix
so if you ever see him anywhere chat him
up he'll be more than happy to
please don't do that that's not funny
netflix's elevation of ted sarandos to
co-ceo
pushes the company closer to its true
home hollywood
so okay hold on a second haven't we
learned the lesson that
co-ceos don't always make for a great
time leadership in a company ted's been
at netflix for 20 years
okay he's the head of content and the
whole idea here is
this is morphing from a technology
company
to a content company and uh they've won
plain and simple netflix one but
yesterday stock was down almost ten
percent i think
five percent something like that why big
numbers well
two reasons one ted was announced as
co-ceo
not really but that's pretty funny i saw
somebody tweet and say damn
rough first hour on the job because they
got announced the stock
no it's because of earnings uh so they
underperformed what people thought
uh and of all people you know who had a
great
call on this mr dave portnoy from bar
stool sports
so all of these analysts were expecting
oh kovid you know netflix is going to
be exploding so many people are going to
be signing up for netflix yeah
whatever and dave said what is true he
goes
you're telling me that you went through
the first three months of uh
covid with no netflix and then all of a
sudden you're like i think i should go
get netflix now like i think now is the
time to do it
in this quarter of course not so what
ended up happening was everyone was
expecting this
you know monster quarter they did pretty
well but it didn't live up to
expectations and therefore the stock
dropped i wrote somewhere that uh
netflix was like
telling people no no we have enough
content to make it through 2020
not 20 yeah they act they added 10
million
subscribers in the second quarter that's
crazy and have almost 200 million total
subscribers think about that for a
second
10 million people signed up in the city
they charge right now is that 10
or 15 dollars no that's more than that
great signal
for a great bundling business talk about
bundling here where they've taken all
these pieces of content put it behind a
paywall they start out 9.99
oh actually a lot of people don't know
this netflix actually started out much
more expensive and they dropped the
price
and then they started raising it again
um i think that it started out at 9.99
and then once they hit a certain tipping
point and they people were locked in
they weren't going to leave then they
started to raise the price
so i think now it's like 13.99 maybe or
12.99 something like that
um 12.99 yeah see everything but that's
not bad i mean
it's not but it's also a uh
33 increase in price right so like
oh are you just doing free advertising
for starbucks right there
hey starbucks call me no we don't need
to do this advertising
so they raised the netflix uh price by
33
so if for a company that's doing
hundreds of millions of dollars in
revenue
literally you're just creating revenue
out of a simple price change
but it's just it's so global that like
remember when we were in bulgaria my
17 year old cousin is like watching
netflix and of course
it's pretty crazy well 192 million
subscribers if that was just the us that
would be
two-thirds of the american population
right so every two two out of every
three people
so obviously it's not all right what's
going on with flip what the hell is
flippy
okay so white castle is testing a burger
grilling robot
named flippy also guys we adopted a new
robot
friend into our household yesterday
i think he's too traumatized to talk
about it but i'll talk about it
i yesterday there's a robot in my house
chasing me around
he got on the couch yeah this was scary
tell me what it is what's it called
roomba um so we got a roomba
and it began to you know clean
and but for some reason it kept going
where anthony was and he got scared he
started it
literally was chasing me it goes like
eight
miles an hour no not even like 0.8 miles
an hour
it literally was chasing me i could
everywhere i went in the house i kept
showing up and hit me in the feet so i
just
got on the couch i was like yo leave me
alone dude yeah and go back to your
little
port he was he was on a call and i was
like it's not gonna make any noise
and i and i started it started beeping
and talking and like making a bunch of
noise
all right so white castle has a burger
flipping
robot story so yeah so then i had to
tell it to go back to its home and it
was just really sad day for me but
okay so white castle is introducing a
burger grilling robot
and it might flip the entire restaurant
industry
i'm an investor in a robot restaurant
nobody cares okay so
beta go check it out oh no for real
huh it's a big ass robot this is the
white castle robot you see on the screen
here
but basically the one we invested in has
a big arm
and it makes breakfast sandwiches and
coffee and you can order a head on your
phone
and then when you walk to it it
basically has a like a port
and it tells you which one is yours and
then you go and you just grab whatever
the sandwiches that you ordered in the
coffee
it's awesome yeah we invested like two
years ago
that's cool lots of big investments
flippy is an automated
kitchen assistant um and it's gonna
start
in chicago in september and yeah
i mean a lot of people are obviously
worried that the robots will take away
the human jobs
but i think this is more of like a in
times of covid uh
a tactic so that people won't touch the
food that's how they're presenting it
but
the whole the whole industry is gonna
get become
robots of course by the way the robots
are better at the job than the humans
humans don't like to say that but no of
course they are it's a robot
it doesn't get tired it doesn't complain
doesn't show up late it doesn't ask for
a raise
and it doesn't get sick and it has
quality control
so yes you have to get the robot to the
place where okay it
understands exactly what to do but once
you perfect okay flip the
uh burger every time the same way all
that kind of stuff
that's exactly what happens yeah all
right what's going on with the island we
should get a robot in here but not a
roomba thing we should get one that
makes me food all right what's going on
with highlands
we'll make yourself food an entire
island off the irish coast sells for 6.3
million
after only a video tour so
a 157 acre private island just sold
and the buyer never actually visited it
how much money do you have to have to
spend 6.3 million on an island
just be like whatever damn it's a lot
6.3 million isn't that much money for
that
but i don't think there's like anything
on this there's like
they have houses oh yeah whoa
okay there's there's six houses they got
a 4 500 square foot
six bed property with 157 acres for six
million bucks
well damn between each one
how do you find they got other islands
for sale between 1820 and 1874 horse
island was home to a thriving copper
industry
with a population peak of 137 people
damn look at how cute this is they got
any other islands out there
look we'll look if anyone knows of any
islands for sale hit me up i'm
i'm uh in the uh i'm in the market for
buying an island
since when okay i'm gonna send you to
the island that's fine
it'll be an escape from my new married
life
you've been married for like literally
five days
guys all right that was a trunk that was
a trap and i avoided it
okay so one more bonus one okay
princess beatrice she was supposed to
have a big
uh buckingham palace wedding this march
i think it was or may
and she just she and her fiance just got
married with 20 people there
in a private ceremony who is princess
we've talked about this before she's the
one who like worked in new york
and like finance or something but she's
actually a princess because she's uh
she's uh william and harry's cousin
did you know i'm a king no but isn't
that cool that people are doing all
these like kind of
mini elopement things no this is stupid
no it's not who cares about what this
woman does she is she's ninth in line of
succession that is
closer than you are no i'm the king of
my own kingdom
so i'm number one she's number nine
right anyway i think it's cool
they got married in the secret ceremony
with only a few people and they were
like
screw the massive you know royal wedding
we were gonna have
uh this might be an inappropriate
question but i see very quickly on the
screen says she's the elder daughter of
prince andrew
uh is prince andrew the jeffrey epstein
prince andrew
oh i think it is it's okay
my whole attitude just changed why are
they talking about her why why are the
articles not saying she had nothing to
do with her father's indiscretions
but they should say the eldest daughter
of a man who is accused publicly
disgraced prince andrew
yeah the publicly disgraced that's what
we're going to call him now
that's literally how we're going to
describe well there's no real like
charges against him he was just what are
you talking about
there's a woman who literally is
claiming that he raped her
i know but but he hasn't been charged
with anything yet
an underaged woman claims and has a
photo with him
that's it and gazelle maxwell not
gazelle
galain gazelle whatever go to jail
all right so are you ready for my joke
yeah hit me with your joke
i got a joke no no all right um
did you hear about the new restaurant
called karma
no i didn't hear are they open there's
no menu
you just get what you deserve
[Music]
that's a smile really
restaurant karma up in here every day do
you know why the uh pony couldn't sing
the lullaby
wait we've done that one before um
because it was a
a little horse nice i was trying to see
if you remembered that one
that's gonna be part of my stand-up
routine i'm gonna walk out and say hey
guys i got no good jokes but here's the
bad ones and then just rattle off all
the jokes you've said
all right guys that's it for lunch
monday today while she's trying to get
rich the rest of us just trying to get
our lunch money right
hopefully pelina will stop wearing this
georgia shirt that she has on because
everyone knows the florida gators are
better
and we will talk to you on monday
please go out have fun wear a mask be
kind to each other
and go get money get paid see ya
and talk to him if you see him
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block 5
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polena they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange i personally
use the interest bearing account
there's not very many places where
you'll find up to 8.6
interest on a deposit in an interest
bearing account
go do your own research there's risks
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfy
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends